christian good afternoon whether you're
going out to the strip here or you're
going to a local grocery store
restaurant you don't have to put these
masks on anymore according to the
mandate changes made today live look
here at the strip this evening a lot of
people taking those masks off some
people still wearing them though we
headed to a local coffee shop bagel cafe
where the people there customers and the
owner were excited for the changes
it's been almost two years of these mass
people were excited to learn the state
is no longer mandating the mass be worn
in public i was at bagel cafe at buffalo
and summerlin parkway when the news
broke some were confused at first some
employees ditched the mask right away
owner savas andrews says he has been
waiting for this i have customers they
come from
texas and florida is oh we don't have to
wear a mask over there why do i have to
do it over here and just it's a constant
like aggravating
it's i'm excited carla ahrez is an
employee she says it has not always been
easy to work with them on it's amazing i
mean you go to florida you've never even
had to wear a mask so it's awesome that
we finally decided to get rid of them
back out here live to the strip you can
see a lot of people without their masks
walking around well we did talk to some
customers at bagel cafe today and they
were happy to take those masks off one
woman we did talk to say it's nice to
have that choice so if you want to put
the mask on you still can of course